so today I want to actually discuss uric
acid and how you could detoxify uric
acid from your kidneys and from your
body most people have this idea that
uric acid is primarily a waste product
only but it has some other functions
that you may not know about number one
it can act to stimulate the nervous
system okay because the chemistry of
uric acid is very similar to caffeine so
it's a neuro stimulant it can actually
bring up your mental focus even though
it's a it has oxidative properties
it also has antioxidant properties as
well it can help to neutralize very
reactive compounds like something called
hydroxyl radical and hydrogen peroxide
and even chelate iron
because excessive iron is very very
harmful in the body another function it
actually can help your immune system so
it's not all bad and there's several
ways that uric acid can build up in the
body
number one fructose is one let's say you
consume a lot of chocolates also you can
actually increase more protein and even
being in a high carb diet and then
having pre-diabetes or even diabetes can
increase your uric acid levels but
fasting and this is what I'm going to
talk about fasting it's a certain point
can spike this uric acid because your
body needs these this antioxidant in
certain studies it can increase between
4.1 milligrams per deciliter to ten
point seven milligrams per deciliter so
it's gonna spike up but it's like a bell
curve and it comes right back down now
if you're susceptible to getting uric
acid kidney stones or gout there's a
couple things you need to realize maybe
you need to increase your vegetables or
decrease your animal protein okay
because of this if your urine is
slightly too acidic okay you'll have a
tendency to retain uric acid in the
kidney if you just alkalizing you're in
a little bit what happens is this uric
acid then can actually come out to the
kidneys and you can urinate it out so
when you look at uric acid levels let's
say there
I in the blood if you're doing a test
you really have to understand the whole
picture and realize that it may be
having these other effects it's not all
bad but if you wanted some symptomatic
relief here's what you could do you can
actually take potassium citrate which is
alkaline you can consume more vegetables
which I think you should do you can cut
down your proteins you can also take
something called sodium bicarbonate
which is baking soda a real simple
solution you take the teaspoon not
heaping in 12 ounces of water dissolve
it drink it in your fasting state maybe
right before you go to bed but don't
drink it right when you're you're eating
because that will neutralize the stomach
acid and it might be harder to digest so
to recap these two remedies are more for
a symptomatic relief ultimately you just
need to increase your vegetables
decrease your protein to correct this
imbalance so that way your pH can be
correct alright thanks for watching so
if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that